SPEAKER_00: Disasters rarely begin at the moment of impact.
SPEAKER_00: They begin when a system gets used to explaining away what it should have stopped to understand.
SPEAKER_00: Challenger was a long sequence of accommodations, each one easier to defend than the whole chain would have been.
SPEAKER_00: The smoke at T plus 0.678 seconds is why the story should not start with the explosion.
SPEAKER_00: The first visible warning was small.
SPEAKER_00: Then it vanished.
SPEAKER_00: For a while, everything looked normal.
SPEAKER_00: The same thing had already happened inside the organization.
SPEAKER_00: A warning appeared.
SPEAKER_00: The system explained it.
SPEAKER_00: The launch continued.
SPEAKER_00: That is why the next case belongs beside Challenger.
SPEAKER_00: THERAK25 is not another space story.
SPEAKER_00: It is a smaller room, a medical machine, a software interface,
SPEAKER_00: and operators trying to explain errors the machine was not built to make visible.
SPEAKER_00: The form changes.
SPEAKER_00: The pattern does not.
SPEAKER_00: Confidence moves faster than verification.
SPEAKER_00: Next time.
SPEAKER_00: Therac 25.
SPEAKER_00: A medical machine that exposed what happens when software confidence outruns the evidence users can see.